do you think because like women we have
the right to an abortion do you think
men should have the right to a financial
abortion
can you explain that so a financial
abortion is basically um
when
so if i'm pregnant right i can say oh i
don't want to be a mother and i can have
an abortion do you think men that don't
want to be fathers should say you know
what i don't want to be on the hook for
child support i don't want to have
anything to do with this kid
and if it was up to me she would get an
abortion but she's not so i want to sign
a reign sign away my rights do you guys
think that men should be able to do that
i think that's fair okay i mean if they
don't get a say
um
in the abortion and they have like
clearly stated i i don't want you to
have this child
um
why not okay i agree i feel like that's
a lot of the issues that we have today
as well with regards to that um
yeah i feel like
there needs to be um they should have an
input
yeah i'm so quite 50 50 because if
you've agreed to have the child then
but they didn't they didn't agree yeah
so basically um
he says he wants her to get an abortion
she says no but since she has the right
to say she doesn't want to be a mother
does he have the right to say i don't
want to be a dad yeah
we've got some based women today we got
some bass shout out to you guys there's
a lot of psychological problems that can
occur isn't it because you've you've now
you've now um was accord enforced
you you're forcing them basically and
it's just out of their power out of the
world and if they can't financially care
for the child
yeah
how many dads that are in that situation
get called deadbeats yes
because if a dad there's plenty of men
that would not want a child that may not
have gone into a situation wanting a
baby
but then when the baby's there is there
that's the reality of the situation
and they may not want to play a part
because they didn't want the child so
they'll get caught a dead beat they'll
get frowned upon by people that know
their situation their family might
disagree especially their families
religious and you've got traditional
backgrounds cultural cultural
underpinnings there'll be a problem
there with that
so
oh it's difficult because
i think that you have to take
responsibility before the child is born
before you can see that child yes you
need to take responsibility for where
that
interaction is going
like i agree with you i think men should
take care of their kids but i think it's
one thing to say they should and then
put a gun to their head and force them
to and i just think if we're in a
society that abortion's legal i
personally don't agree with abortion
like if it would be illegal if this was
pearl's world but it's not right and so
abortion is legal so if that's going to
be legal then
then why shouldn't if women get to say i
don't want to be a mother why shouldn't
men get to say i don't want to be a
father
because unfortunately you've had sex and
there's a baby i mean but unfortunately
she's had sex
but unfortunately she's had sex and
there's a baby it's the same thing with
like wherever you ain't know because the
child is there yeah but that's that's
the thing even with weight it's there
they just pull out the
body parts one by one crush the head and
suck it out sorry
if the woman gives birth the child is
there i've seen that video by the way i
think we've seen the same thing yeah um
if the child is already there
the child is innocent we none of us here
asked to be yeah we're so lucky to be
born right but the child was innocent in
the womb
i'm not advocating abortion i'm just
saying that i know the child's born but
so
looks after the baby
right right so i i agree with you but
i'm saying in this case abortion's legal
so if abortion's legal shouldn't it be
the same for men
shouldn't men get to have a financial
abortion
yes since abortion is legal yeah if you
want that that balance yeah because we
can't obviously give birth ourselves so
yeah i see what you're going with yeah
it's just a bit of a i don't know i i
totally agree with what you're saying
like the argument you're making is a
valid argument it just makes you feel a
little bit
funny inside yeah we do live in a
gynocentric social order so that's why
it's called the grey area that's
that's it you got me there so can i just
um
a point you may add to a point you made
earlier about you know if your stepdad
the the child knows that um you're not
the dad no matter what
i think again that goes back to what i
was saying about that being such a
thankless job you know i was
20 the first time i ever sat down on my
dad and thanked him for being in my life
my whole life right and how many people
can actually say they've ever thanked
their dad for being there no not many
because you just think oh he's meant to
be doing this anyway but it's like
i only deep to only realize how lucky i
am to have a dad in my life when i was
in uni and you know a wall broke in in
our uni house we had to pay for it and i
was like oh wait i know how to fix this
because my dad told me and my dad was
around this whole time so
it's it's a crazy thing that you know
your stepdad would be there so long and
the kid knows it's always that but i
think
when that kid grows up if you raise him
well
he will he will most likely thank you
for what you've done for being yourself
i hope so yeah
i actually hope so
for my personal situation
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna read some super
chats real quick um
guys i who just gifted a bunch of
memberships shout out to you they gifted
like 10 memberships
um p4g we got a bunch of members in the
chat welcome to our memberships guys
you're going to see exclusive behind the
scenes content on top of that you are
also
going to get the the second half of the
show is going to be members only chat so
you get the members only chat privilege
okay so
nh what's even worse is the csa is a
business the kid only receives a
percentage of the fee sent by the father
i'm sure it's around 40 of the figure
the uk economist if mothers were better
at raising kids why are so many young
people in gangs and committing knife
crimes that come from single mother
homes
kai ken there's there this is a grown
man alone and drunk with a woman saying
he's oh i read that one already let me
refresh the page hold on
um
okay
90
free toe pie how are you my little
cayenne pepper i am i'm good i don't
think that like cayenne okay i don't
know how to take this i think he's
taking a liking to you
okay that's all the super chats do you
have any more questions sarah um
[Applause]
you have one okay man all right well go
ahead all right we could do like one
more my question we're talking about if
the man or we always talk about if the
man doesn't want the kid and the woman
wants the kid what if it's the other way
around and the man wants the kid and the
woman doesn't want the kid that's what i
want to talk about i think it's world
that the man has no say at all whenever
that child is born or not
like if i've been in that situation so
yeah you've been yeah it's it's wild
like if i want to if i'm saying i'll
take care of that kid
and you're still having an abortion even
and she can do this even when you're
married like it's ma it's wild it's wild
i i think
i mean i don't think abortion should be
legal so if it was up to me that would
be a legal procedure
what do you guys think do you think men
should have a say in abortion
yeah because it's their is their child
being born as well okay you know i think
it's a joint commitment
in the idle world i would it would be
great to have 50 50
with that but
once you were bought like if a guy wants
the baby right
if the guy wants a baby once you were
bought if he's if you two are together
for instance right and you say you know
what i know we're together but i don't
want this child
does he just is he ever right just leave
you after that
do you think he's just like all right
bye
that's a big thing you know that's a
that's the same as like marriage
if he wants to get married and you
didn't right that at that point in time
and you say like i'm not ready